so the melodic one off July Eddie asked
me some crazy questions about Jenna so
stay tuned we'll discuss the answers
bismillah alhamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you that's the best
greeting that one can give that's that
greeting of peace and this is what every
Muslim is striving for peace peace with
the Creator peace within himself and
peace with our brothers and sisters in
humanity this is what the Muslims are
striving for that's right a Muslim is
simply one who adheres to what God
Almighty the creator the one God the
same God that Jesus worship the same God
that Abraham Moses all the messages of
God including the last and final
messenger problem Hamid peace be upon
they all came with the same message it's
one God one recipient that recipient is
mankind and God Almighty didn't send
religions he sent one religion one way
of life and that's been that way of life
that's been there since time immemorial
it's not submission to the One God
that's how you get peace you already
learned something you're gonna learn a
lot more you're gonna learn a lot more
about Islam and Muslims here in the DCO
so don't go nowhere we have no Menelik
on we're gonna be talking about
something that all the messengers of God
brought taught we're gonna be answering
your questions but I get kind of excited
we asked we talk about the questions and
whatnot and I want to ask them about
paradise paradise so we got your
questions and we got my question in the
questions so don't go nowhere
another exciting episode of the Deen
show we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
assalamualaikum peace be with you
Michael said I walk alone oka no man Ali
Khan it's good to be here it's like
yesterday I was saying that you were
here and time is flying and it's like
it's gone and what do we got
you know hum did love we got some more
time to do some more good inshallah logs
up this from us I mean we're really
excited that you're here we're gonna get
into answering that we did in our
previous show in some questions we get
some of the viewers who write in an
email in and from time to time we'll
answer some of their questions people
like these questions you don't answer
and taking the time to answer somebody
but we don't do the fit questions right
but we want to talk about just some
basic things but you know before that I
just want to open up if you can I've
heard you myself talk about Jenna
paradise you know and I think before we
get into it can you just for me you know
can you just spend a few minutes because
every Muslim we know is one who submits
to the will of God to the one guy the
same guy that Jesus Moses Abraham the
last in front of message of promise
submitted to and they all came with the
same message do God's will not your
desire and they all came with the
warning right if you you know follow
your lusts and desires you turn away
from God you're heedless there's a hot
place for you but then they gave this
reward this paradise that if you do good
you stand upon good you love God with
all your heart all your mind all your
soul you do God's will you got paradise
and I heard you and it touched my heart
and you talked about paradise you know
and before we get into these questions
so I think it'd be motivating you know
to kind of uplift people's spirits I
know why they're doing this why are we
submitting why are we doing this
you know it's for paradise isn't it I
want to say two quick things about ya
Hellfire first yeah well my favorite to
favorite ayats in the Quran one of them
is my afraid Allahu be either become
what's God getting what's God going to
get out of punishing you anyway what a
beautiful thing for a lot of say that's
what Allah the crater's must said that
what's he gonna do punishing you so it's
not like he wants to punish you it's not
there to punish you he tariff people
have a this sister came to me one time
and she said why does God talk so much
about Hell in the Quran his fire burning
skin oil this that why I'm so terrified
of it that's my problem with him and
with his lamb because it's so much talk
about Hellfire I was like would you
rather hear about it gets scared and get
your act together we'll be in it mmm
isn't it a mercy that he told me about
it before I have to see it
true true yes he scared me out of my
mind
of that place and then he told me I
didn't create you to punish you and I'm
letting you know look there's a horrible
place don't go to it it's like he opened
two doors and he showed me what's locked
behind both doors and then he says look
you have a choice to take whichever door
you want now you're blaming him for
showing you both doors if you only
showed you Jenna you say it sounds nice
but I'll take my chances
right and you where you a need ever told
you about hell he never told you what
you that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
whether you like it or not doesn't
change reality you could say I don't
like traffic hate it that doesn't change
the fact that it's still there you're
still stuck in it buddy right what do
you know about Hellfire or not doesn't
change the fact that it's there it's
coming
it's a lost favor that he told us that
it's there and you notice it says in
Lemoore rahim arabic when i daddy
Cocalico my second-favorite i about the
subject he says except the one your
master shows mercy to and by the way
that is why he created them in order to
show them mercy Allah says in this ayah
the purpose for which he created us on
his and on our end the purpose of our
creation to worship Him on his end the
purpose he created us so he could show
us mercy subhanAllah
what a beautiful beautiful perspective
on Allah the first introduction we have
to Allah in the Quran is that easy
merciful people think of a some they
start thinking of Hellfire first thing
we should think is Allah wants excuses
to show us mercy now how easy that Allah
make our our Lord make us to earn
paradise
how many opportunity before you get into
that you mentioned mercy how many time
because it just popped in my head
and not to take you off from the main
question but you have a lot of opponents
of Islam disease they say exactly what
you say that you know Allah is a
vengeful God he just you know he's not
loving you know how many times his love
actually mentioned in the Quran love is
mentioned all over the place in the
Quran actually one time a Christian came
to me and said your God is in love our
God is love show me in the Quran where's
God love I said ok I opened it up
wah wah wah wah dude Allah says he's
extremely forgiving and he's extremely
loving just walked away
look where's the love brother right but
the idea is its it is there and this is
it is a central concept in our religion
but Allah calls it a two-way street
like everything else don't take
advantage of like how many people are in
a loving relationship but at the same
time it's abusive the she loves him and
he abuses her but she still loves him
that love is abusive and on the other
hand also there are parents who get used
by their children out of love right it's
an abusive relationship Allah doesn't
allow us to abuse our love of him it's a
mutual exchange I've heard I know we
don't like in the Creator to his
creation but I've heard an analogy made
of a father you love your father but you
got some fear there you know what I mean
keeps you in line but it's not that your
father he loves you and you have this
fear just to keep you on track mm-hmm
and on that idea of making comparisons
between ourselves in the Creator we
don't compare anything to the Creator
but the relationship we have with the
Creator can be compared and Allah did
that himself this is okay too
relationships can be compared yeah but
then we say the way Allah does that is
an infinitely superior to this yes this
is what we can imagine how much more is
Allah so it should you know now talking
about paradise a little bit you know the
thing that personally fascinates me
about paradise this is just one thing I
mean there's so many descriptions of
gen9
right there's rivers flowing and cups
being offered I used to wonder why our
cups being offered and unless is what
our cups that are placed what's the
point of that you ever throw a barbecue
you ever go to somebody's backyard and
they're throwing a barbecue and they buy
those cups from like Walmart and Costco
and they're serving drinks or whatever
all right that's a little you know
homely party you have to go pour your
own drinks you ever go to an expensive
restaurant like a really elite
restaurant you gotta pay 50 bucks just
to sit down
what do you see on the table before you
even get there comes there's 1,400 years
ago Aloha Allah knows how we think
mm-hmm Allah says water flowing rivers
flowing you ever been to the lobby of a
very expensive restaurant hotel mmm what
do they have you ever been to the CEOs
office of a corporate executive top
floor in New York City what do they have
artificial waterfall same thing Allah
described you ever seen a commercial
where they take you to go take a
vacation in the Bahamas or take a
vacation and you know Hawaii or
something escape to paradise it says
what do they show you a palm tree water
drinks relaxation this is in the Quran
the verbatim would have gotten this is
these are the pictures they show you on
TV commercials right yeah what does it
let ascribing this is what but well this
is what Allah is the way alone alleged
ascribing water flowing trees fruit
drinks people reclining and relaxing
enjoying each other's company and you're
looking at that and going wow these guys
made a commercial about escape to
paradise and it's like they read the
Quran it made that because Allah knows
what he's talking to he knows what we
want he knows what we want now look at
this I don't even care about what
religion you are everyone as they get
especially men and even women as they
got older and older you know what
there's one thing in our head we get
it's programmed you can't even get rid
of it there's a love of a beautiful
house you go through a nice neighborhood
what are you gonna do that's nice yes
look at that yard oh my god oh my god
did you see that one you people can't
help themselves I don't care what
religion what background you're from
everybody has desires to save up and
have a stable place to live they don't
want to live on rent they want to own a
place what I have a nice out anyone is
just the
they like it what does al offer in
Paradise it's incredible he says I'll
give you a house and it'll have what's
the most expensive real estate in the
world beachfront property Manhattan is
one of the most expensive cities in the
world what's the most expensive part of
Manhattan anything that looks over to
the water yes and the higher up the
higher up the more expensive and a lot
puts my houses on top of mountains
mansions they overlook the entire garden
they overlooked the waterfall these are
things that Allah put inside our psyche
he wants us to desire these things in
this world so that when he talks about
these much the much superior version of
that in the next world
that we're truly one of it we say if
this mansion can exist here oh my god
what does a laughs remain there if this
beautiful vacation spot the oceans in
Calif the beaches in California the
canyons in Arizona you know the
waterfalls in Arkansas if that can exist
here what does Allah have for me in
india ferrah
what is he what what amazing thing is he
gonna give me you know amazing amazing
we're gonna I'm getting very excited I
love talking about Jannah paradise we're
gonna talk some more and we promise to
answer some questions of yours here on
the Deen show don't go nowhere hope you
put your dream home and you've got your
dream car but you're gonna get old and
things are gonna happen to you in your
life and then what have you got at the
end of the day is an empty dream that
has no real foundation we are gonna dine
and we're gonna meet our Lord and he is
going to judge us it becomes an
obligation for each single human being
to find out what the Quran is Islam is
telling us to stay away from things
which are bad for your person and bad
for the society
[Music]
it's killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious back here on a
Dean show with the CEO of baina
Institute no man Ali Khan on the dean
show back on the Dean show he has his
own private section at the Dean show
calm hum did it la you're back I love
you for the sake of haha I didn't even
know that yeah I'm really excited and
come to light in Charla
you got a prize every time you in
Chicago hopefully we can we can continue
about any battler we got it okay so
listen I'm very excited like I said
before that you know every time every
every breath is a blessing that the
Creator has given us and I love talking
about Jenna paradise before we go to the
question just just tell us so to get
Jenna to get paradise what are the
simple things that we is is something
really that complicated if you think
about what do we have to do to to
achieve eternity bliss perpetual
happiness does it ever get tired you
ever get tired bored and Jenna know you
don't ever get bored engine now that's
one of the joys of Jenna you have
beautiful company in Jenna you know over
in this world when we take a vacation
especially we take a vacation with the
family kids might love it it's a
nightmare for parents right because I
didn't take care of everything and that
when people get together for a break
like you know Christians got together
for Christmas break maybe families get
together for Eid break or something
fights break out arguments happen things
that there's supposed to be a time of
celebration at the best celebration best
celebrations but will you're with others
and what happens arguments right this
must be a happy time what happened here
you know people cry and get weddings and
things like that right the here Allah
says in general one of the great joys of
it first of all Boredoms taken away a
second of all you get whatever you want
third of all al in this ill feeling
towards each other is eliminated we're
not even capable of it in general you
can't even say something I heard
somebody else's be no more xanax this
it's gone go it's gone so you only have
this beautiful relationship you know
sometimes husband and wife get into
arguments and they don't even know where
it came from like they're both confuse
like how did we end up here how did this
conversation even start why did he get
so nasty that
we'll take that ability away from us
Anjana we can only have wonderful
conversation I love something I'm
looking forward to like it peas being at
peace all the time you know when people
are happy they're sit there man I wish
life could be like this all the time and
they know it's not gonna be they know
around the corner a problems coming
migraines coming something's coming
whether it's physical emotional
something's coming just to know that
there's nothing problematic coming you
know one of my favorite favorite places
enjoy and mentioned in Paradise is this
guy who makes it to Paradise so little
soft thought he makes it to paradise and
he notices his friends sitting there in
there all this hey man you made it do
and they're kind of congratulating each
other you'll be having those talks yeah
do you like oh my god you're from there
you're from there and we're just getting
to know each other all over again I
remember you and then you wonder what
happened to my best friend I don't see
him here so he from way back in the day
back in this world he remembers his one
friend missing from this group and he
goes up would you like to know what
happened to him and nobody else
volunteers but he wishes to see his old
friend so imagine this in John now Allah
opens a window so he can see his friend
in hell okay so this is a scene
described in the 37th surah so he looks
the guy burning in Hellfire his best
friend you get to see this now you see
you get to see this from jemna
cousin gender you got anything you want
right so he wanted to see his friend
wish granted you get a view into
Hellfire and you see your friend burning
it and he says look I'd get that or Dean
you almost made me fall off the cliff to
man he looks at his friend doesn't it
you okay can I pull you out he doesn't
say that I said man you almost took me
to the party with you that was the guy
trying to take him to the nightclub
that's correct
he goes you made me almost got me you're
the one who used to make fun of my
really juices are you too extreme what
do you mean we're gonna go back to
paradise or there's gonna be a Hellfire
you're the one who used to crack jokes
with me about religion you know that you
were that guy and then now imagine this
guy who's in Jannah looking at this and
saying oh thank God I didn't listen to
you because for a second there I was
thinking about it right so he put all
the windows closed but this guy has just
seen Hellfire do you think he's shocked
and horrified he would be even though
he's an agenda he just saw Hellfire
so he comes back in the agenda and it's
like he just got here for the first time
the words in the Quran are amazing I
find I'm a newbie my guillotine are we
not gonna die anymore
really but wait you already knew that
he's a juggler but when he saw a glimpse
of Hellfire the most beautiful thing he
could appreciate about Jenga first and
for like it's a reintroduction to Jenna
was the first thing he says I can't die
anymore
except that first death we already
tasted you know and that's then the
second thing you appreciate up well I
want you to imagine what this is the
second thing he says that he loves about
Jenna now I imagine trees mansions
friends waterfall all the food you want
amazing things around him and what's the
number two thing first thing we're not
gonna die anymore
what's the number two thing he says this
is the most amazing thing ever number
two reason we're not going to be
tortured there's no more pain that's the
second thing he appreciates why because
he just saw what pain looks like
subhanAllah as Jenna amazing amazing
somebody just came to my mind before we
answered some of the questions someone
from the outside you know everything
makes sense in Islam you know but
certain people are trying to confuse
people to get them off that path of
reaching of submitting to the Creator so
they throw out certain allegations
against Islam a lot of false things
statements and one of them is that look
your God is just creating this paradise
and all you guys are just seeking
pleasure it's all about pleasure and
have you heard this argument yeah what
do you say about this well I say lots of
things about that so that's the first
thing I say about that so there's
pleasure but you run after pleasure here
and you're telling me I'm a criminal
because I'm running after pleasure that
God gives me for earning good deeds and
pleasure is something Allah put inside
you deny there's such a thing as a
pursuit of pleasure
nobody does everybody is looking for
pleasure in this world God is telling me
put the brakes on act ethically and act
decently in this world and I will all
the things you held yourself back from I
will let you have I say why not I just
need to argue all the Islam is you know
you might have a younger audience that
Islam's offer such sexual rewards in
paradise that's one of these you know
and it's you know this beautiful women
and this and that I say to you you have
a young man
who goes to college in this country who
goes to campus in the middle of the
summer he sees a half-naked women all
around him and he guards his eyes he
doesn't make they make small talk with
him he doesn't make small talk he knows
he keeps telling himself Allah has got
better for me a las got better for me
Allah has got better for she looks
beautiful but I'm not gonna look I I
can't I can't I know Allah has better I
know you know how hard that is for a
young man to do and a light at the end
of the day says Bravo you did well you
know what you did you deserve something
everything you've held yourself back
from here you go it is not that we get
these you know lustful rewards in
paradise
it's actually that you guarded yourself
against the most strongest urgent man
can have how many psychologists talk
about how many times a man thinks about
sex in a day you know I mean some even
count like every 30 seconds or every 40
seconds or some psychologists are tell
us I call it 30 40 60 2 minutes even two
minutes it's seen how much this thought
runs in the mind of a person how much it
can and add to that we're living in a
time where pornographic images filthy
ads shameless is constantly being
bombarded in our face how much even more
and in the face of all of that a man
guards his chastity a woman guards
herself why shouldn't they why shouldn't
they be given the best reward the most
beautiful spouse ever imaginable why
shouldn't they be given that they'll
both have whatever their heart's desire
whatever their hearts man and when
anything they want they can have agenda
that's correct okay and if you know if
you think well what I'm gonna want is
gonna be evil evil itself is removed
from your heart you know whatever you
want will be good anyway whatever you
want is good in and of itself and you
will be so pleased with it because when
I say good it doesn't just mean it will
be boring it means it'll be good it will
be pleasing to you and good for you how
many things in this world are pleasing
to people where they're not good for
them people find pleasure in drugs don't
they yes but they die from them too
mm-hmm people find pleasure in alcohol
they get sick from it too they get into
car accidents from it to pleasure
something pleasurable and something good
for you is never the same except in
Jenna and Jenna it's gonna be good for
you and pleasurable for you both at the
same time how about seeing the face of
our Lord is that one of the things that
that's the ultimate that's the ultimate
seeing Allah our Creator I'll give you a
comparison I know Allah is the highest
comparison but you know if you're just a
small employee in this huge company with
hundreds of thousands of workers you
just started working there as an intern
you'll never see the seal see is on the
news you know you work at a post office
means you work for the government you're
never gonna see the president but
imagine you got invited to the White
House the post office worker the clerk
got invited to the White House he's got
a private one-on-one meeting and instead
of you extending your hand president
extends his hand says welcome he honors
you
and then he pours a drink for you how
honored would you feel oh my god what
are you doing for me that's a human
being that we think has honor now
imagine the slave of Allah among
billions of slaves on this earth from
the beginning of humanity to the end of
it how insignificant would he be before
Allah and Allah says salamun qawlam mir
rabbir rahim allah the masterful the
merciful master is going to be saying
Salam to him he's gonna be saying peace
to him he is congratulate saluting him
and in Lusaka Abu Hamza Rabia hora their
master will give them to drink imagine
Allah offering you to drink it's these
scenes that are described in Jannah
there there beyond our imagination but
when we hear of these scenes you know
one time somebody asked me what's the
what's the big deal about paradise
anyway what do you get I just told them
drinks what's in my mind is Allah giving
me drink what more can I ask for it
amazing we're gonna don't lose your
place we're gonna take a break and when
we break bad God willing with some more
here on the Deen show
[Music]
not afraid to stand alone if a box by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone
I am Not Afraid
[Music]
there always be someone that will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive also just hold
onto the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe can rely I need a last
minute
the Quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't feel old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us if you're
famous you know Allah said that the
Prophet SAW shall have never ever
stopped a war against anybody and if
we're gonna worship something I figured
I might as well worship the Creator
instead of any of the creations now in
upon investigating the religions I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what most limits those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will dies
Islam was pure it was just you just
praise her God you're creating back here
on the Deen show some came I was going
to tell you off air but I start you know
why not share with with our viewers also
I say I was thinking so inshallah if we
make it to Jenna if we strive and we do
what our Creator wants us to do and we
please him before we meet him and then
we're in Jenna and we can be talking
about remember we're on the Deen show
talking about said may Allah grant
agenda and all those that are striving
to to be good to be upon good to please
the crater before they meet the crater
and to do his will not their desires and
we mean we can't we got to tell the true
we said we're gonna answer some
questions I got taken away with the
topic Jenna I know and I love talking
about it so and hopefully insha'Allah
that some of these questions now can be
already answered because the person
who's saying I want to be religious but
something to stopping me
hopefully they heard about Jenna's
motivation this would be a motivation
he's bad company maybe it's laziness
maybe it's your addiction to
entertainment turn the thing off erase
the games off your phone for God's sake
good
get a life really how people are so
addicted to entertainment now and then
they say I can't feel anything in prayer
well what a surprise
you have to get off of the screen you
just have to get off
you know it's ironic we're gonna be on
the screen but if you're gonna be on the
screen being there for something
productive you get motivated to play the
X bar and to win the game and beat
everybody at it yep right and then you
turn into a couch potato at the same
time it takes it makes you less of a
human it really does
the only thing you can compare people
playing video games what what other
creature can sit in the same place for
hours and hours and hours and not move
what animal on the earth can do that
even a snail is slowly trying to move
from its position right there's a really
pathetic state for a person to be in to
sit for two and a half hours before a
movie and the only time the muscle moves
is for a popcorn to go into the mouth
hey you know this so it what a surprise
you're not motivated you know that this
is one thing bad companies another a
company that's in itself addicted to
entertainment what's it gonna do for you
you have to be around people that are
intellectually stimulating that are
doing good things around you and a big
thing also is to not be alone especially
for young people when you're alone you
are shaytans lunch you're done you're
gonna end up doing the wrong thing I
guarantee you you need to be around in a
safe environment to be alone go to the
mush didn't be alone go to the mush it
goes sit in the library don't be alone
don't be alone especially not in your
home but you have an internet connection
at home I don't need to say more don't
be a cruisin for a bruisin that's it
that's correct so you get motivated and
you win the NBA championships you put
your mind in it and now you're like
Michael Jordan and you win the game and
you sit there wasting your time okay you
get motivated to get a diploma right
even a GED you get motivated right you
get motivated to go chase that lady or
that man what about motivation to seek
the pleasure the one who created you you
know this this question was asked also
by one of your other writers I can't
find a balance between this world and
the next Dean and I now have a I said
there's no struggle
everything we do in this world is for
the alfetta if your intention is right
if you're going to work for the right
reasons if you're staying away from evil
deeds if you're remembering a loved one
you're supposed to if you're eating what
you're supposed to eat if you're saying
what you're supposed to say you can live
in this world and have a great time
and still learn your Jinnah Allah
doesn't want you to have a horrible time
in this world you know we I don't know
why we have this concept but we have to
kind of cut ourselves off from this
world to earn Jannah no no no you have
to make the most of this world to earn
Jenna we have very little time on this
earth I mean most of my half of my life
is spent sleeping and the few hours that
I'm awake take away the time I have to
relieve myself get dressed for work stay
in commute to the job put in the eight
hours at work and come back what I have
to three hours of free time technically
free time then I actually have some
control over how about I make the most
of that free time you know that could
change my life those few hours that you
have free after work or that commute to
work instead of listening to useless
news you know about the weather and the
Dow Jones Industrial Average I watch you
listen to something productive in that
time listen to some Quran listen to
something that'll increase your
knowledge listen to you know a good
discussion that'll help you understand
things better memorize doors at that
time do something more productive and in
the in your free time do do good things
make a routine out of going to the
Masjid regularly you know every I shall
you catch every action before you start
your work till you catch every fudger in
the Masjid me I had some small good
routines in your life and how much good
will come out of your life is amazing
another of your listeners asked how can
I improve my character step one do no
harm stop doing bad things don't talk
about adding good deeds until you get
rid of bad deeds mm-hm
you know you can't talk about giving a
patient medicine until you stop the
bleeding first it doesn't make any sense
you know so you got to stop the
entertainment addiction you got to stop
the the watching the filth you got to
stop you got to start lowering your eyes
when you're walking down the street
because you're becoming less of a human
every time you stare at a woman and you
stare at her like she's a piece of the
piece of meat like she's an animal that
just means you've lost respect for a
fellow human being that's all that means
to you that's nothing nothing but you're
looking at her like an ape looks like a
female ape you know like a dog looks at
a female dog that's all you've turned
into an animal regain your humanity
first and then embellish beautify your
life with good deeds do simple small
things get perfect your prayer
memorize a few supplications try to you
know be honest in your workplace be kind
to your mother these are not complicated
things this is what the Creator wants
from us that's only one but if someone
says wide why does he want this from me
what what is it this is benefiting him
that's a great question
everything Allah wants from us is his
one of his name is al honey what do you
mean someone who doesn't need anything
and he told us that in in an ayah in
which he basically told us to do certain
things and he's funny and he's really
wonderful for Cara you're the ones that
are bankrupt now in that ayah he doesn't
need anything and we need everything
because we're bankrupt and then he told
us to do a few good deeds and if you do
a few good deeds he will make you honey
he'll make you free of need he'll give
you shower you would blessings not only
our good deeds beneficial to us because
they in and of themselves are like
medicine but they bring with them
bonuses in this world and the next world
you'll be kind to your mother and you
never know you'll be looking for a job
forever and you're also mean to your mom
you start being kind to your mother and
mysteriously you get a call back I want
you to come in for an interview the
blessings of being kind to your mother
one good deed will open up other doors
for you this is what Allah does in this
world who ever becomes conscious of
Allah is your Elohim a collage and he
starts making the doors open for them
making a way out for them well your home
in high school I act as if he starts
providing him from what he couldn't even
imagine all because this person became
conscious of Allah right that's all of
us asking us up and he's asking us for
us to make our life better
last comment Allah says you know people
say what does God want it's a really
fundamental question what does God want
there's a few ayat that tell us the
answer one of them as you read allahu
leo - co-vocalist but in sunder Haifa
Allah wants to lighten your burden and
the man and him the human being was
created weak you think you're making
your life easier by partying you're
making it harder I want East for you I
want to take the burden off of you you
just don't understand it you're too weak
you know how Allah so
paradise that's the GP GPS what we
should have it set for get there the the
game plan is obeying God before we meet
God
and obeying him is only gonna bring
goodness in our lives any any closing
comments anything else we have to wrap
it up that's it what do you what else
you for the viewers now for my viewers
are and the viewers of the show first of
all congratulations on this fantastic
effort I really really respect this
effort and I recommend it all the time
Milas would bring a lot of good from it
to me to people all over the world and
accept all of these deeds from us Tommy
for every second that is viewed I mean
the viewer be rewarded may the people
that are involved in this program be
rewarded inshallah this becomes our
ticket to paradise I mean we collect the
checks later insha'Allah
so that that's one thing I really wanted
to share the second thing I wanted to
share is that you know this kind of
effort it should inspire even the
viewers that are in our audience to
become more motivated to do good deeds
how small efforts think things like
YouTube how they've transformed the
world right things like small things
like Twitter where you just put a little
hashtag and can create revolutions in
the world now so don't underestimate the
value of small deeds you might think
it's just an hour worth of effort 20
minutes worth of effort and out you know
but when allah empowers that deed it can
change the world you know so don't
underestimate the power of the small
things that that you do and ask allah to
empower them with his butter cup with
his blessings i mean thank you very much
my allah the creator of the heavens
earth reward you thank you very much my
pleasure being here and that was my
brother and your brother Naaman ali khan
give me some great advice a great
description of Jenna paradise what every
human being should be striving for
before you meet your Creator work to
please your Creator and you have one
shot to get it right this is the test
it's the test of life and God Almighty
he sent the verbatim word God the Quran
that's the instruction manual and the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
the proper home and peace be upon them
it's all there it's all there so don't
waste time get to know this beautiful
way of life and then you'll see the
beautiful fruits that will come from
doing this way of life Islam submission
to the one God and this is how you get
peace pick up the verbatim word of god
call us at